- Pour leur première conférence
de presse depuis un mois etau en
arrivent avec leur masqueet ilsr
l'enlever, question de s'assurer
qu'on l'a bien remOILEAU, direc.
de santé publique du Québec
- On invite les gens
à être prudents et,
à reprendre le port du masque.
- 10 jours après l'avoir retiré
la santé publique n'a pas
l'intention de réimposer
le couvre-visage nulle part,
mais l'objectif ici, c'estler qe
demeure efficace, surtout
pour les personnes vulnérables.
- Moi, si je me retrouvais dansi
que ce soit, je le porterais...
♪ ♪ ♪
semblaient suivre son exempl
aux Francofolies de Montréal.
Mais à Québec, où on termineèns
du Festival d'été,
des gens se préoccupent
de la montée des cas.
- J'ai vu ça avec les fêtes
de la Saint-jean qit
plusieurs personnes... pas de
masque. Ça m'inquiète un peu.
- Avec une santé précaire,
Louis Sansfaçon veut
Il a créé l'Immunoclip :
une épinglette sur son masque
LOUIS SANSFAÇON,
instigatmmunoclip
- Quand tu vois le "i", qui
représente un petit bonhommeemie
du mot "immonusupprimé", bien,
ça dit : "Fais attention à moi,
garde tes distances,
ça peut être mon frère,
ça peut être ton fils."
- Les nouveaux variants
demeurent moins virulents,sible,
et comme l'influenza
a presque disparu des radars,
ceux qui ont des symptômes
Dr JEAN LONGTIN,
microbiologiste, eique
- En ce moment, on a quand même
tous les éléments qui fontpense,
est-ce que cette vague sera
d'une ampleur comme la 5e ou
la 6e? C'est là que c'est
- Un autre appel à
nation est donc lancé,
particulièrement aux malades
chroniques, aux immunodéprimésEs
vaccins diminue avec le temps...
- Tous peuvent avoir accès
à une dose de rappel dans
la mesure où la u moins 3 mois.
- La santé publique
répète donc le même message
que les dernières semaines
au sujetne ramène pas non plus
de restrictions sanitaires, mais
elle agite le drapeau jaune en
espérant ne pas sortir le rouge.
Radio-Canada, Qué